a responsive website changes based on
the characteristics of a device this
means that your responsive site needs to
apply different styles for different
devices there are a few ways to
selectively apply CSS the easiest is
with media queries media queries provide
an easy logic for applying different
styles depending on device
characteristics like its width height or
device pixel ratio you can change
everything from background images to
restructuring the site's layout and even
more adding responsive styles is easy
simply include an additional stylesheet
in your page with a media query let me
show you how to write one